on en a fini pour le grand un
maintenant on passe au grand deux
et c'est les états-unis et l'environnement
à l'échelle internationale
donc en petit a
on va parler d'une position
en marge des politiques internationales
en faveur de l'environnement
par exemple giec ou algord euh ont reçu des prix nobel
pour l'environnement
mais donc depuis deux-mille-dix-sept
comme je vous l'ai dit avant avec trump
ça a vraiment euh baissé
et il y a eu un frein en fait au niveau de l'engagement
donc tout le monde le sait euh
le régiment climatique
peut avoir des conséquences sanitaires
très importantes
surtout au niveau de la pollution atmosphérique
donc il y a beaucoup de pollutions urbaines
qui ont des fréquences d'incendie aux états-unis
c'est vraiment très fréquent comme je viens de le dire
mais ça peut aussi engendrer des maladies
respiratoires comme l'asthme par exemple ou autre
et vraiment les problèmes là-bas c'est l'inondation
le cyclone et l'incendie
il existe tout de même là-bas
un parti écologique qui s'appelle green party
malheureusement elle reste encore inconnue
le problème c'est que les états-unis
sont encore à l'opposé du développement durable
parce que y a beaucoup trop euh
de consommation
donc c'est vraiment une société de consommation
donc ça va être compliqué
après les gens pensent que euh
et environnement et l'antonyme de
d'économie alors que pas du tout
on peut avoir une très bonne économie
et très bon en terme environnemental
en fait faut juste changer la vision euh
des choses et pas rester buté sur
cette notion et donc vu que trump est climato sceptique
qu'est-ce-qu'il va faire
il va vraiment faire
beaucoup de fourrage offshore bien évidemment
donc pour l'hydrocarbure carbure etc
heureusement que précédemment
barack obama avait euh fait en sorte que l'alaska
enfin que en alaska une partie soit
je sais pas si toute l'alaska
bref que en alaska
ce soit une amp donc euh une ère marine protégée
et donc on ne peut pas euh l'exploiter
parce que sinon trump aurait fait des horreurs
mais du coup l'arrivée de biden
va relancer quand-même les questions environnementales
aux états-unis
parce qu'il a quand-même déclaré l'urgence climatique
en 2020 il veut ne pas dépasser les 1 5
d'augmentation du réchauffement climatique
même si ça va être impossible
et aussi augmenter le budget de l'agence de protection
de l'environnement pour favoriser les initiatives
des transitions économiques
euh écologique
pardon mais du coup euh
je n'ai pas encore vu l'actualité avec ma prof
donc euh je pense que je ferai un récap
sur l'actualité de ce qui s'est passé euh
aux états-unis avec l'environnement
parce que je n'ai pas regardé euh
du coup si ça a bougé ou pas
mais en attendant euh je sais juste ça